♪ ♪
>> Neil: ALL RIGHT, IT IS NOT
A DONE DEAL YET.
EVER SINCE THE WORLD'S RICHEST
MAN DECIDED TO BULLY 180, I WILL
AFTER ALL BUY TWITTER, I GUESS
IT IS NOT A DONE DEAL.
IS GOING ON?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY MOVING
PARTS, HE NEEDS BANK FINANCING
IN A TIME BANKS ARE MORE
RELUCTANT TO LEND MONEY,
PARTICULARLY ON HIGHLY LEVERAGED
DEALS, IT IS NOT CLEAR IF THEY
ARE GOING TO PUT UP A COUPLE
MILLION THAT THEY WANTED.
HIS OWN STOCK, TESLA, HAS
DECLINED 30% OVER THE PAST SIX
MONTHS SINCE HE FIRST BID, SO
THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF HERE.
MY GUESS -- AND THE GAS OUT
THERE, AND WE WILL BE EXACTLY
WHAT IS GOING ON -- HE IS
LITERALLY, THEY DON'T BUY AT
FACE VALUE WHAT HE IS SAYING,
THAT HE HAS THE OFFER READY --
>> Neil: WHO IS "THEY?"
TWITTER PEOPLE?
>> WHEN I TALK TO LAWYERS AND
PEOPLE IN THE KNOW, INVESTMENT
BANKERS, THEY JUST DON'T BELIEVE
IT IS THAT SIMPLE, THERE IS SOME
WRINKLE --
>> Neil: HE HAS FINANCING, WE
SHOULD SAY --
>> WE THINK, BUT NOW WE HAVE TO
WONDER, IF IT DOES NOT PAN OUT,
HE HAS OBVIOUSLY OTHER MONEY,
COULD HE USE THAT OR WOULD HE
USE THAT?
>> Neil: THAT'S THE PROBLEM,
WE THINK HE HAS FINANCING, WE
DON'T KNOW, AND THE FINANCING
MARKET IS A LOT DIFFERENT.
BANKS LEND THIS MONEY, AND THEY
TRIED TO SELL IT, THEY GENERALLY
DON'T DO IT IF THEY CAN'T SELL
IT.
THE SELLING MARKET ON THESE
LEVERAGED LOANS IS VERY
DIFFICULT.
IT IS ALL UP IN THE AIR.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN TAKE AT
FACE VALUE WHAT HE IS PUTTING
OUT THERE.
I THINK, STILL MY VIEW, HE WANTS
TO GET THE PURCHASE PRICE DOWN.
HE DOES NOT WANT TO PAY
$44 BILLION -- 5420 A SHARE --
AND THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE SEEING,
YOU ARE SEEING THE DANCE AT THE
LAST MINUTE, AND IT IS
FASCINATING.
IT IS ALSO KIND OF FRUSTRATING
TO COVER BECAUSE IT IS LIKE
STUFF THAT KIND OF LEAKS OUT
THERE EVERY NOW AND THEN, YOU
LOOK AT HIS TWITTER PAGE AND HE
SAYS SOMETHING CRAZY.
>> THE JUDGE INVOLVED IN THIS,
RIGHT, SHE IS A PRETTY TOUGH
JUDGE WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE WHO
PROPOSE A DEAL BACKING OUT OF A
DEAL, SO SHE COULD SAY, WELL,
REGARDLESS OF WHO IS FINANCING
OR WHATEVER, YOU HAVE AGREED TO
THIS PRICE, THESE TERMS, YOU'VE
GOT TO DO IT, RIGHT?
>> Neil: THEY COULD DO THAT.
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THAT DOCUMENT
HE SIGNED SAID.
THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED A
MATERIAL ADVERSE CLAUSE IN THERE
WHERE IT SAYS SOMETHING MATERIAL
HAPPENS THAT YOU CAN'T DO IT,
GUESS WHAT, YOU CAN BACK OUT,
PAYING A BILLION DOLLARS OR SO.
THAT MATERIAL ADVERSE CLAUSE
COULD BE THE BANKS NOT DOING THE
FINANCING, AT $44 BILLION.
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> Neil: BUT WOULDN'T A JUDGE,
CHARLIE, SAY WHO CARES, YOU'VE
GOT THE MONEY, THIS IS THE DEAL.
SHE IT IS IS STILL ON, YOU'VE
GOT TO DO IT.
WHO WOULD BE THE BLOCKING PARTY?
POSSIBLY.
>> I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY --
>> Neil: WHAT YOU THINK
HAPPENS?
DO YOU THINK THIS DEAL WILL BE
CONSUMMATED, OR IS IT OFF?
I CAN'T SEE ANY OTHER BIDDERS
OUT THERE.
>> THERE IS NO OTHER BUYER.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM TWITTER HAS
BEER BUT HE DROPS OUT AND ALL
THEY GET IS A BILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF HIM, OUT OF A BREAKUP
FEE, WHO IS GOING TO BUY IT?
THE STOCK GOES DOWN TO $20 A
SHARE.
MAYBE THEY NEGOTIATE HIM DOWN A
LITTLE BIT AND AVOID SOME OF
THIS.
THE STOCK IS ALREADY OFF A
LITTLE BIT.
LISTEN, IT'S A GREAT STORY.
IF YOU ARE A SHAREHOLDER, YOU
HAVE TO BE BITING YOUR NAILS.
I CANNOT TELL YOU WHERE THIS
THING WILL GO BECAUSE WE ARE
DEALING WITH A GUY THAT, YOU
KNOW, DEALING WITH ELON MUSK IS
LIKE NAILING JELL-O TO A WALL.
IT'S JUST -- IT'S JUST ANOTHER
LEVEL.
HE PREVARICATE SCUM HE
FABRICATES, HE SAYS X COME HE
MEANS Y.
HE REALLY IS AN AMAZ